service about performing uh yeah I am  I'm always nervous before I perform so  but it's a good nervous energy I mean  I mean I don't I feel very comfortable  with myself this is me  you know because it's one thing to  record but to get out there and actually  do it and perform on stage and to see  the audience's instant reaction it's the  best feeling in the world that's when I  feel like at home my children whenever I  do anything they come with me so it's  really interesting to see they're like  is that Britney Spears or is that you  Mommy I'm like it's the same person  my main thing is to enjoy life and take  today take one day at a time and I try  to live by that and I feel like as women  I feel like it's really you know  powerful and sexy for girls to have the  image of empowerment and to have a  little bit of an ego it's okay